but normally we put it over there right
are we doing it just for today's deal
yeah okay that's fine gentlemen we're
live five four three two
john you scared people doing it the way
you just did it right now we're trying
to have a friendly podcast here he jumps
out of nowhere anyways today's podcast
will wit wrote a book
how to win friends and influence enemies
which i love the title because one of
the first business book i ever read was
how to win friends and influence you
know
are people but you have influenced
enemies i love that
uh this man uh he's got audacity he goes
out to talks to people in the streets
he's got nearly a billion views online
you know a lot of work i still work all
the time and i love your work i love how
you are you're respectful you ask the
questions you allow the individual look
dumb if they answer a dumb question you
know their answer is bad but you have
fun with them anyways will it's good to
have you in the house hey it's good to
be here guys thank you so much
appreciate it a lot yes a couple things
i want to let everybody know so you know
what's happened with the podcast last
few months this is just something i want
to tell everybody we hired
uh a ridiculous booker okay and this guy
that we have rob shout out to him he's
booked me with guests for six months out
now
what that did for us is the format of
pbd podcast has kind of gone from the
you know morning day to day we would
talk about current events it's gone to
more interview style if you're listening
to this
uh what we are going to do is my
schedule today i'm trying to commit to
doing one or two of them per week where
no matter what tuesdays and thursdays we
cover current events so be patient with
us because we still have a lot of
different appointments uh guest schedule
but within the next two to four weeks
we're gonna go into the model of
tuesdays thursdays uh being the
day-to-day so i think tomorrow we got
sync from young turks which should be a
fiery by the way i would have missed uh
tomorrow's podcast tomorrow live right
here senk his company which i'm
surprised he said yes which is exciting
uh because i think the audience is going
to win with somebody like that so pat i
think it's important that you are
letting people know what's going on like
you know we got so many things moving
and grooving and we got the poker going
on two things have changed a couple
things i don't want you no i'm not gonna
put yourself out what are you going to
say i'm not saying anything i'm just i
think it's important that you update the
pieces well that's all i'm going to say
i got you i got you yeah but there's
some major things that's going on that
were you think i'm listening
i'm thinking you know you know some
stuff okay that's cool anyway just
letting you know that
here's the story of my life and then
we'll this is today's show we're gonna
it's gonna be about you but the story of
my life is the following i love being
underestimated i love being thinking
like people are not
planning with what's going on patience
long-term big thinking we got some major
major announcements coming very soon
super 8 we have how's the meetings been
the last couple weeks i've been having
say i have future looks brad anyways be
patient having said that will for people
who don't know your story if you don't
mind taking a moment and sharing with
them your background yeah no problem so
i grew up in colorado actually i live in
los angeles now working for prageru but
grew up in colorado i was a liberal
atheist my entire life basically go
around to everyone who i knew and tell
them how stupid god was how dumb
religion was and that was a lot because
my father growing up was actually my
older brother my dad was in prison when
i was growing up so my older brother
kind of took that place he had a
different dad and his dad was very
atheist and and
political in that sense and so that
transferred to him and if anyone
listening has an older brother you know
that i mean you do everything that your
older brother does much more than you
four years okay so a lot older and just
a lot different life that we live
and so growing up liberal atheist and
when i went to college everything
changed though because i went to cu
boulder if you guys know anything about
the most
liberal exact college out there
yeah you think that most people go to
college and they become
more liberal or they were raised
conservative and become more liberal or
leftists especially in a place like
boulder but for me i mean when i saw the
the lunacy it turned me the other way i
said wait this is there's a lot of
things here that are absolutely
ridiculous it don't make any sense you
know being in a sociology class and
political science course them talking
about how bad just mutual transactions
as capitalism is and about you know i'm
not allowed to to speak because of my
race all sorts of things like this and
eventually i became the one to always
raise my hand in class and tell my
professor that they were wrong and all
the other kids
it every single time
i was that guy i was the one who
everyone hated which was fine with me
without an agenda you were more just
questioning this because you had you had
a certain set of beliefs and you get to
college and you're like this just
doesn't jive with common sense is that
what happened i mean that's exactly
right it doesn't none of it makes any
sense when you i grew up in an area in
colorado called aurora colorado which if
you guys know that it's outside of
denver and it's kind of it's not the
best area you know i was a minority as a
white guy going through high school and
middle school and all that and so i grew
up around a lot of black and hispanic
kids and these types of things that this
white ta at cu boulder is telling me
about you know why privilege and the way
that races work together it just wasn't
true it just wasn't true and will you're
how old now 2065 25. yeah so a lot of
times when people talk about college so
like i'm 42. pat's 43 yeah 43. okay so
we talk about college
on that one right
you know we talk about when we were in
college you know 20 years ago or
whatever it was or when you were in the
army
dude you were in college like five years
ago yeah give her 10 years ago so this
isn't like when i was back like you were
there right during the trump years yep
yep so okay so dealing with all the drum
and all the nonsense so there's anybody
who has literally lived
you know that you said the atheist
leftist sort of mentality and now you're
obviously a little more libertarian
right i don't know where you are right
yeah i'd say more conservative than
liberty okay conservative
but you know
get back to your story but i just wanted
to address how old you are 25 years old
you're young for for
to have this kind of kind of common
sense yeah i mean exactly what you're
saying i remember in 2016 when trump won
the election this was my sophomore year
of college and
all these kids were having these circles
where they're all holding hands and
locking arms and kids are crying on
campus and i show up on that day with my
mega hat on just no you didn't yeah of
course you know he won the election and
other you showed up with the hat on
but sometimes you know you got to show
these people and say look i'm not scared
because you're crying what was the
reaction oh you know people cursing at
me and you know getting upset with me
you know but no fights nothing like that
nothing like that nothing that okay so
but what i would do because i i hated
college for the classes and everything
like that so i would go on my campus and
i would set up a table and i would just
go and debate kids on all sorts of
different topics whether that was
socialism or feminism minimum wage
whatever it was and then my professors i
was supposed to be in class they'd pass
by and they'd see me just out there and
be like why aren't you in class i'm like
well i'm doing this this is what i like
to do and so after two years of school i
dropped out of college and i was able to
get a job with prageru by making a video
on my campus where i asked women what
they thought about the wage gap and i
taught myself how to edit the video
shoot the video borrowed one of my
buddy's gopros and prageru ended up
loving the video and and they they moved
me out to los angeles after about
six months after i dropped out of school
my sophomore year and now i've been in
la for about
four and a half years now four and a
half years how's it late right now you
know it sucks i'm actually spending i
actually just flew in from amsterdam
last night uh and i got engaged get out
again yeah congratulations
good for you in amsterdam in amsterdam
my fiance is dutch
she's a wonderful typically when people
get engaged in amsterdam it's a
different reason but you you got a valid
reason that's good yeah exactly yeah and
the red light district yeah
yeah i found a real goal
i mean the jokes are plenty but yeah yes
exactly yeah but uh
i had to move i to go away from los
angeles to find a woman so that can kind
of tell you about what los angeles is
like right now it's a terrible place so
you met her in in amsterdam i actually
met her through dennis prager so her and
dennis had met last fall at an event in
hungary and she's this uh legal
philosopher and speaker she's a big deal
in europe speaking about things
her name is ava
and
they met and then i got hooked up to ava
through them and then it all kind of
just came from there and so i never left
the country before and now i've been
going to amsterdam and hungary and all
these different places with her meeting
her for the last four or five months and
we got engaged quite quickly you
literally just met her four or five
months ago yeah yeah isn't that nasty
and now how old is she our birthdays are
actually two days apart we're both 25.
so both of you are virgos that's cool
good for you well congratulations thank
you thank you so so here's
there's a lot of stories for us to get
into okay a lot of stories for us to get
into
uh especially with everything that's
going on right now we'll just kind of
preface uh one biden pitches largest tax
hike in history well i'm gonna have to
cover that 5.8 trillion dollars
mansion shoots it down
71 say biden's america is headed in the
wrong direction
nancy pelosi voted the most unpopular
democratic politician in u.s history
which is very surprising
india and russia working to launch a
rupee ruble trade agreement that
circumvents western sanctions you got
blackrock president saying entitled
generation now learning about shortages
disney having his own issues five
million new jobs open we have to cover
will smith and uh yeah jada and chris
chris jim carrey what he said
thousands of people on twitter went
after the wrong will smith which will
have to show who that will smith is he
just became a celebrity overnight which
is great uh tiger woods michael jordan
tops richard's at the tiger who's been
out augusta the last couple weeks nobody
knows why maybe we know why the most and
least stressed u.s states
prenuptial agreements aren't just for
the rich i left mormon church for only
fans and i got a few things to say about
the batman movie which we'll cover as
well did you see well i can't say did
you see have you had a chance to avoid
seeing
the fight between chris rock and will
smith well i saw everything that
happened i mean how could you when you
saw the word will trending you're like
what's up i know i'm like i know about
my engagement what's going on exactly
exactly
here's a question here's a question i
got for you and then you know i want to
get your thoughts and i'll get mine as
well so
was it
your position for first time when you
saw it has it been the same from the
first moment to now or has it gone i
can't believe what he did well it kind
of does make sense because of jada oh
but you know what i can't believe what
where are you at with what happened with
will smith and jada my opinion has
always kind of been the same on all
these kind of things when i watch
celebrities do stupid stuff at the
oscars or whatever it is and for me i
personally just don't care much i think
that people blow a lot of these things
out of proportion and to me it's just
not something that i'm ever super
interested in i leave celebrities and to
other people but what it seems like in
terms of the whole situation
i don't think will smith was justified
in doing it but i can understand that as
a husband you get angry when someone
says something but you don't lash out in
that type of way i mean it just seems
childish and immature to go up there and
slap someone especially like an open
hand slap like not even a punch you said
that's a [ __ ] slap right there's what
that's called you know it's it's not
like a manly punch it's a slap yeah
which makes it even worse yeah it makes
it even i mean the uh
diaz brothers they're famous for
fighting guys and you have scenes saying
i bitch-slapped you so they liked it
oh have you ever seen this or no yeah
there's videos of all they want to do is
slap you in your face in the fight okay
not a punch too slappy because they get
a kick out of it but what are your
thoughts when you saw this by the way
just just before you even say this jim
carrey did you see what jim carrey said
what jim have to say so jim carrey says
a day ago the video's got like 10
million views jim carrey says i can't
believe
the oscars did a standing ovation for
will smith if it was me and you did that
i would sue you the next day for 200
million dollars did you hear that or no
he said i'm going to see you for 200
million dollars on top of that he says
because that video is going to last a
lifetime this is permanent you're going
to get 200 million lawsuit from me the
next day that's what jim carrey said
who's a comedian going after will smith
what's your position let me tell you
something uh you would think story
somebody slaps the [ __ ] out of somebody
else whoever it is
you assume like the nick diaz nate diaz
whoever did the slapping won and whoever
got their
face [ __ ] slapped would have lost let
me tell you who the big winner in this
the whole situation is chris rock
let me tell you guys i used to stand up
comedy for many years okay
before dave chappelle there was chris
rock people like i don't know if you're
25 i don't know if you really know
how big chris rock was in the 90s early
2000s everyone knows about dave
chappelle these days now it's kind of
moved from chappelle to like kevin hart
and there's other people out there chris
rock was the man
and he's gotten a little softer a little
older a little more hollywood more
acting
when he did like
um his uh what was it blacker
dude you're talking about gangster ass
comedy chris rock
so
this was the best possible thing for his
career you can see the ticket sales have
gone from like 45. show this up minimum
for a ticket to like 400 bucks chris
rock is trending for all the right
reasons and the guy took it like a g
like just
i i thought this was fake i thought this
was planned i thought this was stupid so
if you're watching this if you listen to
this podcast how many of you thought
this was fake at first when you saw it
when your friend texts it to you your
reaction i think sam takes it to me i'm
like this got to be fake and he's like
no it's not fake so mario and i played
the video on you know how on youtube you
can go to 0.25 speed of course you
played on 0.25 speed yeah and i'm like
no i think i think we should bring our
friend paul in here reenact the [ __ ]
lab let will do it yeah i'll do it yeah
bring him in bring him in here
so correctly big winner here
notoriety yeah uh
financial yeah um headlines we just
handled it like a man yeah it is again
he's like that's the greatest moment in
oscar's history yeah okay but now let's
talk about will smith
will smith has been getting emasculated
for the past year or two by his [ __ ]
wife
that he's been married to for 25 years
this whole entanglement red table talk
that they're doing
insanity will smith
was the coolest baddest dude on the
planet for two decades from well from
freshmen
you're right i don't know if there's an
actor that was loved and loved is the
word more than him yeah yeah from from
fresh prince
to men in black
to independence day to ali
you know
to
bad boys i mean the list goes on and on
and on don't forget now you got you got
a pencil i mean all that i mean the list
goes on and on i'm sure there's going to
be someone that's like adam forgot about
this movie and i hate him okay i got it
hitch pitch right damn legend like he
needs
thank you yeah
he needs all of it okay we got it we got
it chris gardner pursuit up he needs to
go back and watch the movie that he
freaking started called hitch because
he's lost his mojo
that like this the whole [ __ ] slap with
chris rock
this has been brewing for years
you think he actually cares about this
joke he laughed at first he left she
ended up laughing at first
i feel like this was just boiling up
boiling up his i mean do you know about
this whole red table talk entanglement
august
augustus whatever
his wife is
literally having an affair cheating on
him with
the son's friend
yeah and now you're like like it was
august at cena thank you john and now
this is him fix your audience
seriously but he's dad bod synth vibes
it just i feel so bad for him think
about even before this years and years
ago the transition that willow has been
going through that his son has been
going through like this this family is
strange
will was the only normal guy is there a
more
hollywood family
out there the father hollywood star jada
i know you have strong feelings on jada
the kids
uh
jaden and willow two of my favorite
songs in the last five years have been
from the smith kids yeah the song wait a
minute
exactly that song icon from jaden like
they put out they they're great they're
very talented no doubt i mean you live
in la you know about like they're
talented as hell
but whatever is going on with this whole
entanglement has
just clearly been burying it down low
and it exploded at the oscars and then
he won the oscar i have a different
opinion go ahead so first of all like
okay who won you're right chris rock won
and i think jada won i think feminist
movement won i think women power one i
think those who give that message i
think they won you have to give them
credit they won like
women are you know stronger than men and
look at how jada is very proud she's a
face of feminism if you think about it
because she's got him locked down right
um
you know who i am you know how i feel
about jada three years ago i don't know
was two and a half years ago hector del
toro and jennifer teamed up together
right after the event i had at the uh
trump tower they had an event they had a
hooked up and they sent me
the uh jada pinkett autograph picture
and it was in my office do you remember
this or no jada pinkett autograph is
sitting on my desk right to the left and
they come look oh my god pat you got put
this picture away i'm like put this
picture away jennifer was up to this
with hector what do we put this picture
away so sitting on my desk because i
grew up with jason's lyric okay and
lyric is jada pinkett in the movie with
one of the best soundtracks that i can
go and tell you the songs in the
soundtrack but i'm not going to
no no no j j you're thinking about uh
you're thinking about with uh janet
jackson that's quite a joke
but jason's lyrics they used to date is
what i'm saying of course yeah so tupac
so so so i'm a i'm a jada guy i grew up
being a jaded guy i always loved jada
right so and i've always loved will so
the fact these guys that was kind of a
cool story now one of my friends 20-plus
years ago
um she would come to me and she would
say you know i know the will smith and i
know jada's story and i know them very
well i said really yeah
and she would say stories and i'm in l.a
20 some years she would say well let me
tell you you know you know they have an
open relationship and they have this and
they have that i'm like
it's none of my business no they but
they do like everybody says stuff and
the moment you become a celebrity people
say a lot of different things and you
can't believe half the stuff no but i
know it personally how do you know
personally i'm just i can't tell you but
i know and she kept being very adamant
like you know somebody's very adamant
and they don't have a trend of being
like that but this one time they're
extremely out of me like okay and this
is a friend of yours this is a friend
you know 20 years ago and i'm listening
to him like okay he says but you also
realize they're like open with
everything with their marriage it's just
a very private thing that this is a time
that there's no social media there's no
facebook there's no twitter there's no
instagram so it's easier to have that
kind of a relationship in hollywood and
they're not the only ones that's having
a relationship so so imagine this
thing's going on all these years they
have an open relationship all of a
sudden all the open relationships you've
had let's just say hypothetically none
of them have come out
it's all been private but this one guy
brings it out
august you know
and the next thing you know oh my gosh
you know will is as simple as this well
is that i believe will is sitting there
saying i wish you guys know how many
people i've been the last 25 years that
none of you guys know about that i've
been behind jada and jada took her
career in the backseat for 12 years for
me to go on my career and she was
popping out one point and she sacrificed
it for the kids you guys don't know how
much i've played around for the last 25
years but i kind of can't tell you guys
on tv because i would look like an idiot
if i do and i'm going to make jada look
bad so i don't think we know the whole
story and i think will is sitting there
saying
you idiots that are saying all this
stuff you're saying about me you don't
notice it's starting to really piss me
off and he reacted that reaction was
very deep that's my opinion i may be
wrong i may not be right with this
i think you're very right but you know
what i'm saying right i think deep down
inside will is
a man's man but i think willis also got
that conservative side because his dad
left you know that one scene in uh
the famous scene with the uncle uh
yeah you know what i'm talking about
like oh my gosh that was not acting and
he's like crying like dude i just got
the chills this dude ain't acting he's
that look he's personally experiencing
this right
will is a guy that many men in america
relate to i just think he um
i think hollywood life is a very
different kind of a life to try to make
marriage personal life conservative all
this stuff work it's so confusing to be
in it you have to play certain car to
get certain jobs to stay relevant to get
the 20 million dollar per film you have
to listen to your publicist you can't
use this word be careful with this
audience those guys said this to you now
you're doing social media now you're
making your own youtube try not to touch
this it's such a big mess that he's
going he's trying to keep his marriage
together but if i can give advice if i
if i'm if i'm in that situation do you
know what i think is the best thing for
them to do right to get a divorce i
think that's the best you actually think
that's what i think that's the right
thing they should do i think they should
get a divorce and move on i mean if
they're already if they're already
sleeping around with other people you
practically have a divorce at this point
i mean that doesn't make a good marriage
whatsoever well let's say they've been
doing it for 25 years dude right right
yeah i mean you should in my opinion you
shouldn't be getting together with
someone in the first place for
appearances or whatever i mean yeah as
marriage you know to me as a christian
as a holy thing getting together with
someone like that and then having
affairs all the time with all sorts of
other people i mean especially when you
were just talking about with i think
there's a difference between men versus
women that if a man goes and sleeps
around with other women it isn't looked
at as bad but a woman who does it
despite her man makes a man look a lot
worse just because of the differences
between the two so that's why people
would call will smith simp yeah but but
i don't i don't know if he okay a lot of
people call him a simp it's easy to call
him that right now i mean you had roll
you know who i don't know you refresh
and fit yeah and they oh yeah he's a
symphony this like they may be right i
don't know if they're right or not but
you know like everybody was trying to
say who tiger was okay and what tiger
did oh 16 this and you know he went
through this and i don't i don't buy his
apology it's not sincere enough first of
all before you judge tiger why don't you
go become the best girlfriend in the
world okay
i mean i read this book the bible that
said what he says before you throw
stones you know
kind of check yourself out a little bit
and i subscribe to that i've never liked
people who judge i grew up in an
environment that was very judgmental i
try to say listen to each his own i've
been married 12 and a half years i take
it one year at a time love my wife we
got a good marriage we got four healthy
kids we've had a great life some people
want to live a different lifestyle i get
it but i don't think the whole world
knows the whole story i think everybody
is speculating and in reality i think
chris did win
i think will is looking extremely weak
and i think will's got to make a move
you know how they used to say to jlo hey
uh your your q score was higher when you
were with ben affleck okay because you
know in the hollywood marriages it's it
pays to be married to the right person
like you better believe kanye and
uh uh what do you call it uh yeah that's
they're like e news yeah i mean the deal
that's like a good hollywood marriage
you're married to beyonce and not i'm
not sure
yeah connie and kim but i'm not joking
yeah that's so i think yeah i don't know
i think if they get a divorce like
listen guys like bezos the husband and
wife the way they got a divorce was very
clear we love each other we've been
together for 25 years yeah this just
didn't work out we still love our family
we still love our kids we have our own
reasons but we have decided to go a
different way we still respect each
other and everybody is like and they
tweeted it same second i don't know if
you remember this it came out same time
you're like
everybody moved on okay it was kind of
like move on i think they got to do
something like that well let me let me
read your red table whatever it is and
say red table top announcement to make
we love each other we love our kids
here's what we're doing let me tell you
why you're absolutely right and one
thing that i think you're wrong about i
think you're absolutely right that
will's been doing his thing for
20-something years are you freaking
kidding me
if he wasn't playing around doing things
like this you think he's going to accept
if he's been faithful for 25 years and
his wife has this entanglement she used
that word she was having a full-on
relationship with this guy
and he's embarrassed by this
if you think he was just being acquired
by this whole time and he's allowing
this to happen
you're out of your mind so i 100 agree
with you
that he's been doing his own thing on
the side whatever like
he's a g bad boys for life type of thing
where i think you're wrong
is the divorce thing i think if they
were gonna get a divorce it would have
been two years ago at this point
i think like they've been through hell
and back
and this whatever is happening right now
is just making their bond stronger
because the world is against they're
saying i'm wrong it won't happen or
you're saying i'm saying i don't think
the right move i i just don't think
all that i don't think it's happening i
don't think they will do it you don't
think i would have divorced three years
ago but wait a minute you don't think
it's the right move today for both of
them mutually to agree to move on i
don't okay and why is that
i just think at this point they're
fixed in together now if if i were will
i would have divorced years ago and now
it's like two screwed up people who are
just
it's like two alcoholics they're just
gonna stay together like drink guys when
it happens nobody will be surprised they
can be surprised when all of a sudden
the world is not gonna go crazy
somebody's gonna i will just give a
super chat by the way you put the super
chats we'll ask some of the questions
with uh will and adam myself
raul says do you guys think masculinity
and men respecting themselves is dying
oh of course there's no doubt about that
i mean you can even just look at it from
a scientific stance and see that
testosterone levels in men are way below
what they ever were before in history so
there's tons of indicators that show
that men are just not what they are i
think a lot of it has to do with a lot
of the food that we eat and just how
feminism has creeped into the mainstream
like this and just like you said how
that was a win for feminism and it makes
men look bad and she's being the strong
one and then will looks bad it's
demasculating men or emasculating men
men aren't supposed to be strong anymore
men are supposed to be on the back
burner and the women are supposed to be
the ones who are supposed to lead now
yeah i think um
i agree with you will uh i've kind of
indirectly
dove headfirst into this topic with the
show that i do sawzcast because we focus
more on dating relationships lifestyle
and like kind of how money factors into
all that
and i've had the guests on like rollo uh
rolo tomasi shout out to him shout out
to fresh and fit and we've kind of
covered this uh
toxic masculinity that's going on
obviously everything that's happening in
like the news with transgender and this
leah thomas william thomas he's the
400th best male swimmer now it's a
number one female swimmer
you know things that are happening with
disney so we've been kind of covering
this and bill maher hit it right on the
head i'm a big bill maher guy
um
he basically highlighted how every woman
is in love with this guy voldemort
zielinski these days
and how convenient it is when a man
needs to step up and be a freaking man
because you're about to get killed by
the invading herd of russians that are
coming your country you know and
everything that be you know to save your
tribe
but how convenient to use that
masculinity at that point but how
inconvenient it is when it's just you
know normal daily life
and that's something that i think people
are grappling with and the women's
movement shout out to women you know the
you know they're getting better
pay gap everything like their career
women awesome
but let's not forget that that men still
need to be men is ultimately what it
comes down to men are doing much worse
in society than ever before in a lot of
ways too killing themselves they die at
work more they're more depressed
especially young men i mean it's
terrible for them they're doing a lot
worse than they've ever done before it's
because of this this this new education
system that tells you that if your boy
acts out in school they need to be
treated like a girl
boys should be taught to be like girls
being a girl is the right type of
behavior and so they teach boys that way
and then you suppress their creativity
you suppress their masculinity and you
get a generation of
feminine feminine men and women who want
to act like men it's like they're
flipping them both on their heads which
doesn't make for a good society you
can't have a society like that by the
way this leads me to the go ahead oh no
did you see like the number one clip on
the valuetainment short clip channel uh
for the last couple days what was the
clip again tyler was uh repeating
history can't hear your audio uh yeah
we're repeating history civilizations
fail when men become less masculine yeah
so torsha shout out to torsha who was on
with rolo and i she basically
explained
how
back in the was it old greece
and greek times
that they they studied history and when
the sculptures and the artwork started
changing from masculine men you know you
know whatever you know posing or
whatever it was
to like more like
doing like more feminine poses
that that is when
um that pose was a little too natural
but yeah this isn't natural i don't know
if you can't let me guys i'll do that
again yeah but that's when um history
started declining or the greek
civilization started declining when men
stopped being men
and i think that's just something that
our audience will appreciate is that
just be a man man up
and uh it's something that
i think we more men need to talk about
yeah i mean it's too much dionysius and
not enough apollo in terms of the the
greek and it happened the same in
ancient rome because you had this at the
end of ancient rome you had this very
decadent society where men were not
responsible for anything because it's
not just about you know wearing skirts
that makes you more feminine it's about
not being responsible being a man means
being a leader and so when you have men
that aren't leaders and live in some
decadent easy society where you never
have any hardships which we have in
america today you can watch porn uh
whenever you want to get off you can go
on tinder instead of going to a bar or
something to get a woman you can order
food you can have someone pick you up
you never have to struggle with with
much right and so when a man doesn't
have anything to struggle or anything to
overcome i mean i'm not sure if you guys
talk to many you know younger guys but
i'll talk to a lot of people who are my
age my friends and we'll be talking
about like world war ii or
some medieval like the the storming of
uh like 1066 battle of hastings or
something we're all just like we wish we
could go to some more like that you know
it's like men today crave something
greater that they don't have so crazy
having a higher purpose what's the
famous quote uh hard times create strong
men strong uh men create good times good
uh good times great weak men weak men
create hard times and that's it's
cyclical right so we can all have to do
a study history and kind of realize what
it is but he's right about that you know
you you hear stories about alexander and
you know the privileges they had to see
who were the real you know
man's men to survive you knew what it
meant to be the survival defeaters and
if you didn't you're going to get
exposed period it's just kind of what it
was and today we are recognizing victims
more than we're recognizing doers we're
recognizing complainers more than we're
recognizing the guys that are quiet and
getting the job done we're recognizing
the loudmouth that gets up there says
this is not fair versus the guy that
says listen i get it let me just go do
my part and order my respect in the
streets we're recognizing the wrong
people last night we had a a friend over
okay a baseball coach here and a dean of
one of the schools and we're having a
cigar uh in the backyard is me him mario
great conversation
with my buddy joel and the conversation
came about
the team he's got the best player etc
etc and i said every great organization
if they have the wrong number one that
organization is screwed okay so for
example you give me a good family that's
got three four kids if the
best kid in that family is the one that
undermines parents all the time values
everything the other three are kind of
gonna be like dude you know i'm gonna
pick up some of the bad habits you give
me a great company with a great number
one they're gonna develop other great
number ones you give me a company with a
bad number one they're gonna duplicate
the habits of a number one so you have
to
position your number one the best today
whoever media points as a number one you
want to be that person forbes magazine
the other day announced the
international woman award goes to
hillary clinton that's their number one
you got all these options to make you
know so imagine an average young girl's
watching and saying oh wow
she's the international i want to one
day be that let me go read her wikipedia
this is what i got to do i'm going to be
like her when i grow up i'm sorry girl
watching better hide her emails yeah so
but the point being we have to be very
careful who we turn into hero i think
america has hero making machine wrong
today by a mile and they gotta fix it
asap and not apologize for it okay you
cannot apologize for it i read a quote
the other day uh posted it on instagram
what's the guys in pj o'rourke is that
his name is he's got the same last name
as you by the way and he said the
following if you want to put it up well
you may not be able to put it up because
it's on instagram
poverty can't be eliminated by push by
punishing people who escape poverty one
more time quote by pj o'rourke poverty
cannot be eliminated
by punishing people who escaped
poverty right you cannot eliminate it
most people like all these rich people
they got their money from their parents
do you know what percentage of people
get their money from their parents and
here's less than 10 yeah eighty percent
of people who are millionaires are first
generation millionaires they had to
figure out a way to make that money you
had the best one you ever had last month
you were telling me about it i'm very
happy for you thank you how did you do
it how did that happen how long have you
been at it how many people tried your
industry and they quit after three four
five years yeah it is not a big easy
business you're in right for you to make
that kind of money in a month he made
the kind of money people don't make in
two years he made in a month that's
freaking awesome to years something like
that now he said he didn't buy any white
shirts so maybe we need to get him to go
shopping i said i wouldn't buy anything
i i need that i probably should let's
talk about this because i think this is
a good transition to going to disney
uh and i'm sure everybody is following
this story it's all over the place and
it's multi-dimensional but i'll read the
story here from daily mail uh disney
president who is the mother of
transgender and pansexual child says she
wants at least half of all future
characters to be
lgbtqia i mean i i re used to remember
lgbtq now it's like qia or racial
minorities theme parks are now banned
from saying hello boys and girls okay
a disney executive in charge of content
kerry burke vowed to up the anti on
gender politics during that all hands
meeting promising that at least half of
the characters in its productions will
will be part of the lgbt community go
from racial minorities by the end of the
year that's half 50 percent right
meanwhile business diversity and
inclusion chief vivian ware said that
they no longer address theme park
visitors as ladies and gentlemen boys
and girls instead as dreamers and
friends the comments after
came after governor desantis signed the
don't say gay bill into law
disney partner nadine smith co-founder
of equality florida said the goal of the
republican bill was to make children
from take children from their parents
what are your thoughts on the story with
disney this is a whole can of worms that
we could really get into i mean first
with the whole don't say gay bill
nowhere in the bill is even talking
about saying gay and then you can't say
gay and all these kind of the words not
even in the bill yeah no i mean my bill
is the word i'm saying gay right now i'm
in florida with you guys right now am i
going to be arrested have my my bank
account
can we bring them in please can we bring
that
it will yeah
it's just ridiculous and the whole part
like look at america's demographics i
mean you have like one percent of the
population that's that's gay maybe it's
up to i think three percent now with the
young people which has also gone up in
in recent 20 years it's gone from one to
five percent yeah we talked about this
with gatsat he was surprised that the
number one from one to five in the last
20 years are those numbers again please
one percent to five percent in the last
20 years people will say that that the
number of people that i identify as the
lgbt it's so high in the younger
generation and that's why this is so
insidious because at least to me it so
much of this is being pushed on children
you go on tick-tock you go on these
places and you see these teachers
talking about transition closets whether
their students can go in and change
their clothes and they don't have to
tell their parents and teachers and
schools are doing it behind parents
backs and
pride flags everywhere i mean
kids don't really know this stuff the
teachers and the the education system
and a lot of the mainstream media as
well is pushing this on children i don't
believe that those numbers are legit the
left will say that oh these these
numbers are because people feel safer
now to speak out about their their
sexuality but to me i just i don't
believe it i think that so much of this
is being pushed on children to influence
them and not all of it is real
i have two points on this and then i
want to get pat's thoughts on because
he's the only one here that has kids so
i want to hear what pat specifically say
on this but pat hit the nail on the head
as he was reading the story he said
you know the
lgbtqia i was like hold on what well
there's more letters now right i
remember when they threw q in there i
was like all right what's what's the
whole cute thing all right that's like
was that whatever that now there's an i
and i literally have never seen the in
the a in there i've never seen that i've
seen lgbtq and this is gonna sound like
i'm a homophobe i'm not i live in south
beach i've partied with gay guys and
lesbians i have friends my ex-girls best
friends was a lesbian couple like i hang
with these people
but you know kind of like what bill
maher said i'll bring it back when you
start to lose people that are actually
on your team and they start to be like
hold on what
that's where you start to lose people i
was an advocate for gay rights sure gays
want to get married they want to be
unhappy like the rest of the people have
at it guys
but now you start to look at just common
sense things here like what is happening
here
now on to the kids
i don't have kids i don't know what it's
like to have to worry about sending your
kids to school and then being
indoctrinated by whoever whoever teacher
teaching them whatever whatever whatever
i don't have these concerns thankfully
so
but as a parent i mean is this something
that like keeps you up at night is it
like do you talk about this in the house
how do you approach it so so let me tell
you when i was 24 years old the guy
asked me uh he says why do you want to
be rich you talk but you want to have
money and i said it's very simple for me
like if people ask like the real reason
for me to want to have money it's very
basic one
i wanted to have a house
that had all the toys and had to park in
a backyard where every one of my kids
friends would say let's go to
patrick's house okay that's number one
okay very important because i can
control i'm a middle eastern i'm not
comfortable with sleepovers you want to
do that you do it at our house and we
got a pretty great security system we're
going to do our part right that was one
at 24 25 years old okay now you were
saying when i had absolutely
when i was when i was i said when i have
kids i want them to go to the private
school that i want them to go to none of
it had to do with the lambo ferrari
whatever whatever right i said i want
the kids to go to the private school i
want to go to i want to control it right
next you know all these things that i
went through service respect i want all
these things okay i don't want to be
judged for being from iran i don't mean
to be judged from being armenian
assyrian this is who i am treat me as a
regular guy that got some value did his
part and then let me decide the life i
want to live okay
that's drive i can't even describe to
you for somebody that's born in iran how
much it matters to me for you not force
anything down my throat i can't tell you
the emotion it generates when you try to
force something down my throat i can't
stand it a a forced thought a forced law
a forced position i must take with my
kids where one uh one time at a at a
model i don't know where we're at and
i'm talking to my kids and one lady's
like you know you don't say that to your
kids i said i'm sorry what this is how i
raise my kids
i said do you have any kids no i don't
have any kids i said ma'am why don't you
go find a partner and have kids and you
raise your kids and let them be
successful and write some books about it
but till then mind your own business
these are my kids i'm raising right
right i was at the whole uh uh art
museum deal you know the art deal i
don't know what the art bazel art
dazzles whatever you invited me that was
great and i'm there before we go and i
look at dylan i look at you guys so look
at me guys i said your brain's about to
get a workout yeah you're going to go in
here your brain's going to see art some
of this stuff's going to be weird but
it's getting a workout okay this is how
art is it it works out your creative
juices i love that mom and a dad is
looking at me and they're like oh my god
i've never heard anybody tell this to
their kids i don't know if i'm raising
my kids the right way or not i'm going
to find out in 40 years when i'm dying
at 83 years old but it's my job i chose
to have kids with my wife it's our
decision on what we did and my wife and
i dictate how we raise our kids and we
are open to feedback and opinion and
strategies that we may consider to do
that but it's our kids and i got 18
years with these guys okay outside of
that go be it okay let me do this part
and i'm gonna find out if i did it right
or wrong we could do a lot of things
wrong but
what i can what i what i'm concerned
about is the following here's what i'm
concerned about
go back when you went to school i'm
curious to know what yours was as well
when was the first time in school at
what age did they start talking to you
in colorado about what it meant to be
gay lesbian and transgender how old what
grade was it let me just say one thing
about what you just said about
about the kids because that is exactly
why republicans want virginia because
you have the exact same mindset that so
many other parents have yeah and it's
because of that of why they want but by
the way that's scary for midterms and
2024 for democrats because they're
realizing
that's something you don't mess with you
can mess with a lot of people you don't
mess with people's kids you can call me
out i can call you out but if i say
something to your wife or if i say
something to your kid i may get a
different reaction from you right go
ahead it was also the critical race
theory and terry mcauliffe right
virginia just the
it
education
basically the phrase that the soccer mom
has now turned into the kobit mom right
and basically
you know
the swing voters were talking about the
the the soccer mom the covet mom is the
reason that trump lost and it's also the
reason that terry mcauliffe lost in
virginia right that's the swing vote
but here's my concern though let me tell
you who i'm concerned for let me tell
you what i'm concerned for
i'm concerned for
the mom and dad who make
48 000 a year okay that can't afford
private school that can only go public
school
and they're in a coding that they can't
go to another public school that feel a
little bit more comfortable about
because the way they zone it with
schools where you can only go there with
zip code and they come and investigate
your id all this other stuff
i am so concerned for that family
because that mother is like kids gonna
come to come home from school confused
and what do you do so we are raised to
tell our kids hey you better listen to
your teacher i'm sorry i'm afraid to
tell kids today you better listen to
your teacher no i don't tell them that
you don't know what i'm saying the
teacher what the public school system in
america has done has turned children not
into creative passionate thinkers it's
turned them obedient to authority and it
doesn't puts them in a box exactly what
you're saying it doesn't make them into
people who want to discover new ideas or
make something very new it's it's you
have this life you live this life
exactly how you're supposed to and don't
deviate from that and if you do deviate
from that if you're a boy and you chew
your pop tart into the shape of a gun
you know you're you're evil and all
these different types of things how old
what grade were you when the teacher
taught you about gays lesbians and
transgenders not that not brother but
teacher right that was elementary school
what great do you remember fifth grade
what grade was it for you i i can't
remember a teacher teaching me about
that i can't remember that i don't know
that wasn't a thing do you remember that
never never i remember i mean i had a
gay major
in junior year high school but they
never taught us about it i i had it in
high school as well i don't remember
anybody ever teaching me about no gays
lesbians and transgender i remember
there was a kid in seventh grade
that
you just knew he wasn't like part of the
boys he wasn't on the football team
that's what i'm saying right um and he
was kind of
he was gay turned out to be gay but we
didn't underst we were we're kid i mean
the mutants kids in the world are eighth
grade kids like like
if i'm thinking of when i was my meanest
self it was eighth grade right and i was
a stand-up comedian could you imagine
i'm looking for laughs everywhere i go
yeah i was not nice to that kid and
years later i saw him i'm like hey man
like we're cool is that but i have a
problem with that as well and i think in
that example uh i think somebody needs
to come in and have the conversation
with the kids
on on that part okay where you know the
bullying part because i i agree i know
looking back at it
listen
if there's anybody that doesn't like a
bully
this isn't like a 1980s jock movie you
know where people are good giving gay
kids swirlies and stuff like exactly
this isn't revenge of the nerds right
exactly this is this is 2022 where now
no matter if you have more
intersectional
ideas about you you're gay lesbian trans
black whatever it is the better off you
are in those types of situations right
so it's really in a lot of ways you see
with young white men are doing worse
academically doing worse socially in all
these places straight men with young
white straight men exactly you know so
now it's like flipped on they over
correct it ain't cool to be young and be
a white straight guy anymore no so the
florida's bill is what that you cannot
talk about transgender and gay uh up
until third grade correct kindergarten
third grade bring it up in school by the
way when i read that i'm like i'm sorry
well you mean fourth grade it's okay
how old is somebody afford exactly
what do you mean you want to bring it up
in fourth grade i don't even support
fourth grade
what fourth grade what fifth grade what
the hell like what are you talking about
so when do you support having that no
first of all like what's health and
guidance
i remembered we learned health and
guidance from kim sinclair
my teacher
her name oh she's my pen pal we write
letters to chill today was this sex ed i
remember taking sex yeah but by the way
she's the reason why i joined the army
shout out to kim sinclair she was my
favorite teacher
she is uh politically on the complete
opposite side that than i am
every guy she dated would go out on a
date and she would say do you like this
guy do you approve of him this lady is
older than me but i play a role of an
older brother and i protect her she was
very good to me i joined the army she
had a very positive impact on my life
she literally has there's a letter
sitting on my desk and i responded back
to her on on text uh thanking her for
the letter but i remember saying i'm
like okay i learned about sex cool i
already knew about it but i learned you
know the whole the banana and the condom
and all this stuff and you're watching
these videos oh okay cool now you're in
what grade by the way health and
guidance in glendale was at 10th grade
that's what i like at that point i'm in
favor of a 15 16 year old learning about
i think that's the age yeah what the
hell are we talking about even being
okay with fourth grade elementary school
should not i am so confused well we're
here we've gone through puberty yeah
here's the thing like
go to the conservative folks that are
like wow it shouldn't be dark but fourth
it should i'm sorry what i'm terrible
what are you talking about
you this shouldn't even start till high
school that you talk about this should
not even be brought up till high school
is when you start having these types of
conversations do you know how confused
kids will be my kids and i were watching
a movie the other day and in the movie
you see a i don't know what it was a
girl kisses a girl and my five-year-old
daughter sitting there says my wife and
i'm like
daddy is that okay
so then i give my position on it
and then it's like oh okay all right
then i'm like turn this damn i'm like i
can't even watch some of the movies that
i so now disney wants to go 50 percent
they were doing a going to the park and
asking people like i'm canceling my
annual membership i'm cancelling this
i'm cancelling that and this is not cool
they shouldn't do this dude they can't
even say boys and girls anymore they
have to call them dreamers and friends
so this if we can't even say hey boys
and girls what are we talking about
how often at any event good evening
ladies and gentlemen i like to welcome
like all the time that's just normal
right but you see what that's
why the these people are so mad about
this don't say gay bill and not being
able to teach it to children is because
think about what you just said saying
boys and girls and ladies and gentlemen
not being able to say that or thinking
that leah thomas is a woman any of these
types of things the only people who have
the brain capacity to believe these
types of things are children
because otherwise it just sounds so
ridiculous to just normal people normal
people just hear that and say this is
just crazy so they influence children
they push it on them young so that when
they get older they believe this all
their life and they know that they're
not going to get out of it when i was in
the army we used to go to this gay bar
best club in uh nashville tennessee was
called connections they shut it down on
03. let me tell you it was
a ridiculous experience it was the
studio 54 of uh what do you call it of
nashville like if you've ever seen a
movie studio 54 that's exactly what it
was i mean
i'm not so i'm surprised they took that
long to shut this place down it was
a
guy took me to this place
yeah why are you going to a gateway
because racials are on your side it was
right actually i totally agree with you
it was just you're a straight guy
there's always girls there you're going
to you're going to bring up time that we
would go there i have when i left the
last time i went to connections we have
a picture two years ago i have the
picture till today
i have the picture until today and it's
in my uh
no joke not the picture till today you
should see the picture everybody hugging
me six of them around me they're all gay
okay and then two of the guys from the
army yeah they're straight and they're
like they're crying we're gonna miss you
greek god you know we're gonna like have
this everybody had their own name and
all this stuff yeah your little little
joke i would tell them i would say you
know so so what what nationality what's
bad david i'm like i'm a syrian
sicilian after like 50th time trying to
explain what the hell is this and i said
you know what yes i'm sicilian so since
18 years old yeah i've had a side name
of a of the greek god vinnie delucci we
go i'm not a joke i'm not
but here's the point it that didn't
bother me but i was 18 19 20 years old i
knew i i'm comfortable i love women i
like this i'm very comfortable in my own
skin i'm good but to start that at third
fourth fifth grade i don't think you
start this still tenth grade and i think
they're you shouldn't start it at all
and at what point at one point in any
education yeah should you be talking
about home like
kids will figure it out amongst
themselves
only one reason look you and i can teach
the concept of stocks five different way
you and i can teach capitalism in five
different ways
you can tell capitals and say yeah
here's capitalism it's the rich taking
advantage of the poor it's kind of like
they have their employees looking at
them as slaves that's your way of
explaining capitalism spot-on he could
say capitalism is the people that
inherited all their wealth from their
family and they had a head start and you
don't so capitalism benefits those with
a head start that's his explanation my
explanation as a teacher of capitalism
maybe listen folks there's many
different political systems in the world
many different economical systems in the
world but the one that gives you the
biggest fighting chance without a
four-year degree without a two-year
degree without an mba without needing a
last name is capitalism it's hard it's a
lot of work it's gonna suck you're gonna
lose a lot but if you work your ass off
you read the right books capitalism's
for you we all explain capitalism yeah
but we explain in a different way the
way you explain
lgbtqiabz whatever the letters are the
way you explain it has to be very
matter-of-fact
here's what you're going to see this is
what this is here's who that person is
here's your approach when you run into
them bullying is not okay no matter who
the person is you cannot judge people it
goes back to very basic fundamentals of
conservative beliefs this whole concept
of judging people needs to go more where
we teach it meaning we teach it more not
to do it i think that's the approach but
the the other side that's like if you
don't you're this and maybe you have
these thoughts and if you do this is
what to do
oh no no stop right there bro chill out
relax
matter of fact style of teaching no
judgment no bullying this is not
acceptable we move on
not the other in-depth type of a style
teaching i don't know if you understand
what i'm saying that but
it's not it's
i mean this is all coming from the
colleges and universities i mean it's
indoctrination from kindergarten all the
way through your graduating year of
college it's straight indoctrination so
it i don't think it should be addressed
at all because it can't be matter of
fact right well that's exactly right
um
i do think their sex ed is totally
appropriate and 10th grade and and you
know call it nine ten whatever high
school and the middle i'm cool with that
i'm gonna give you one little
perspective here and i don't have kids i
don't have an opportunity to say this
story all that often i'm going to give
you two stories real quick
i came into your office one time and
this was regarding my sister
and my sister and i kind of got into an
argument with her and i was like you
know what because she's a big theater
broadway whatever
and
you know i i'm really tight with my
nephew that's my guy rory love that kid
nine years old he's a boy he's a he's a
boy and she's like you know i'm
enrolling him in ballerina classes and
you know i want him to kind of start
doing what i do i go
i go gent this is not what
i no
i
like
she i'm just i know what she's used to
in south beach and dancing and broadway
and i'm just like
rory you won't play soccer right yeah i
like soccer she's like but he could also
learn i'm like
i put my foot down like i'm like i this
is not happening in my house so she's
like you're not the dad i'm like my
masculine tendencies were like this
isn't happening right and i was just
like because i was a sports guy i played
football in college like i this is the
closest thing i have to have in a kid my
nephew like don't even kid's nine years
old eight years old at the time
flipping on you
the most emotional i've ever got i told
her in the store the other day when you
were in the office i was i told tiguan
that the other day yeah he posted a
video together tomorrow uh he posted a
video of daniel like scoring like three
goals guy's a beast okay he's like five
years old yeah and when i was in dallas
i like that was my homie that was my guy
like i would practice soccer with this
kid
and
i was like
not even joking like choking up watching
i'm like look at this guy go look at him
do his thing
five years old and i could just imagine
if a teacher
was trying to indoctrinate
whatever it is to a five-year-old to an
eight-year-old to a nine-year-old my
fatherly instincts are like this ain't
happening bro
so
the the whole don't say gay thing just
like
i think there's anything we're
establishing here what you used with
like the 18 year old i'm sorry when
you're at the the greek god story
dude you're grown up do what the hell
ever you want with your life yeah do not
put your freaking hands on my kid's
brain
and start indoctrinating to whatever you
think they should be doing hands off the
kids
when it figured out as an adult
do whatever you want catherine that's
just said the super chat she says isn't
gage as part of society why does it need
to be taught why are we treating gay
people as different interesting
perspective by the way forward to say
that here's another one this should be
no surprise this is from cove 12k
x12 this should be no surprise as
parents have been outsourcing their
responsibilities to schools what a
freaking that one
name to give you
credit brother you talked about the
favor it is you said the 48 000
household with the mom and the wife and
you're worried about them even if you
have to send your kids to public schools
there is going to be time where either
the dad or the mom can sit down and
actually have dinner with their kids
which a lot of parents won't do read to
them talk to them about the issues of
the day maybe in the morning at
breakfast whatever it is you have to
find time as a parent to work around the
schedule to undo some of the things that
are happening at the public school you
have to be a responsible parent not a
little point
if you don't do it then then
that's your fault that is your fault
parent if you don't do it you know you
know it's crazy
uh
you know how uh this whole thing with
will smith slapping him got chris hart
not chris hart kevin uh chris
we have a chris hart so chris r kevin
hart chris rock totally turned off so so
this whole chris rock situation for his
ticket sales to go from what 45 bucks to
phone to 50 bucks yeah okay i think i
saw something going for a thousand
dollars yeah i'm not surprised because
everybody wants to see what he's going
to say because everyone's going there
for his reaction on that that was so uh
and by the way that netflix special
could sell for 60 million bucks so but
what's it called
so
it pushed will's reaction originally oh
my gosh chris didn't do anything helped
chris out right and chris wins
i think
if i'm running a church today
if there's ever been
the right messaging to increase
attendance it's today
if there's like if i'm a public school
if i'm a if i'm a parent that 48 000
year parent
and i'm sitting there thinking about how
do i equalize that and match it because
you need to match it right
you need to find a lo like there's never
been more important of a type like a
catholic lds judaism whatever you
whatever you are
somebody that's teaching conservative
beliefs and conservative is not
christianity just conservative right you
know stealing marriage biblical
principles all this stuff
i think there's never been a more
important time for parents who can't
afford to send kids to private school
but you can afford to send your kids to
a church i think there's never been more
important of a time to take your kids to
church
like you know i gave a talk in newport
beach to a group of pastors who were
talking about how the donation and
tithing has gone down and you know all
this other stuff and i said just look at
what mormonism is doing they're doing a
great job their youtube channel rocks
they're they're great at getting people
and converting and baptizing until
you're you know everybody leaves for two
years when they go to their uh what do
they call it mission trip that they go
on
i said but today
if if there's ever been a time where
attendance can double triple and you can
again start seeing these massive
crusades of churches being packed with
three four five ten thousand people i
think it's today no but yeah
but those i don't know exactly who those
pastors were that you talked to in
newport beach but there are a lot of
pastors in california specifically ones
that i work with and i'm getting
requests from all sorts of different
churches that didn't shut down during
covid that stayed open and they have
seen their numbers triple quadruple uh
five tuple whatever it might be they've
had so many more people come in well a
lot of the the churches that don't
really speak the truth or speak this
feel-good message of christianity
whatever it is they're faltering and
they're their numbers
i go to pastor jack hibbs church he's
the one who baptized me about a year ago
this uh calvary chapel chino hills and
riverside yeah that's someone i go to
but also you know rob mccoy's church out
there in woodland hills uh a lot of
great churches that are just seeing
explosions and numbers because they're
actually standing up for truth do you go
to his presence do you ever go to
shepherd of the hills do you go to uh
dudley rutherford do you know i haven't
okay got it no dudley rutherford is in
ranch is in the uh portal ranch okay and
he's got a church 20 000 members
incredible church but yeah yeah i think
the attendance got i think as a parent
today if you can't afford to pay 1500 a
month to a private school you can afford
to take your kids to church every sunday
well not just that if you're not listen
if you're a parent and you're gonna vote
pay attention to who you're voting for
it's that simple don't just check a box
on a school board council member they
did this in san francisco they voted out
three incredibly radical school board
members because they were tired of what
they were promoting if you're going to
vote [ __ ] pay attention it's your
responsibility to know a good point
it's a great point but it's not a
realistic point because how many times
you go to a ballot and you check the
ballot box and you vote for the
president the vice president and you
know zero other names and you shouldn't
be on the four pages i agree with you
that you shouldn't be voting
a lot of times like circuit county judge
i'll leave it blank if i don't know a
name or have a any affiliation i will
leave it blank but that's just not how
it works bro like people are going to
vote they're going to check a box
they're going to see an r next to a name
they're checking r they're going to see
a d next to a name they're checking d no
matter what the hell else they they know
they're just going r d and if there's no
political affiliation they're just
incumbent
that's also the problem with the voting
system that's the point is that i
consider myself to be
pretty smart not the smartest but
certainly smarter than most and if i can
barely make out what the hell these
voter you know ballots are basically
saying then i don't know what the hell
most of americans are even understanding
they do that on purpose and i think
you're exactly right of what that's
going to happen but
i think that i mean especially the left
the left will push people to vote so
hard even if they're uneducated and i
say don't vote if you're not educated on
what's going on you shouldn't because if
you're going to be an informed voters
actually care about what's going on you
should be informed you've got a pretty
strong uh
belief system on how the voting uh
system should work
i think your belief system on how to
vote should be the same way companies
and ran or and families around and how
our families ran if your kid doesn't pay
rent money you don't have a voice on
what we buy and don't buy and what do we
really cook
if if you work for a company and you
don't own a share i'm sorry you don't
have a voice right only shareholders get
on a shareholder call berkshire hathaway
has a meeting with their a shareholders
in omaha nebraska where you hear from
him and charlie monger because you
earned the right to go in there because
you own one of their shares at whatever
dollar amount three hundred thousand
dollars
hey sure it is i think we're allowing it
like think about if our voting system
was the way families and businesses ran
that's kind of like me living in my
house with my kids and my kids
six-year-old best friend can come in and
vote for how we should run our household
yeah tell me how that makes any sense
somebody can come and tell berkshire
hathaway how they should run their
company even though they have not
contributed to the organization they
have not contributed to the company's
growth they've not bought a share they
don't risk the risk that berkshire takes
but they want to tell them how to run
things no no your vote doesn't really
matter that much because you're not
contributing to society i think the
system needs to be a way to contribute
to society so you think that certain
people shouldn't have the ability to
vote or certain people should have
a more votes than others i think the
messaging needs to flip to be earned the
right to vote i think that's the
messaging you ought to earn the right to
vote and the current system do you see
that changing at all zero no i don't see
that changing out i'm just telling you
well they have that whole people rights
people have dreams you know i can dream
so it's a very different
people
no they had that that that new voting
thing they said oh republicans want to
take away voting rights from people it's
like no we didn't we wanted to so that
you had to vote on election day so that
you didn't use a mail-in ballot so that
you couldn't be an illegal immigrant to
vote and that you actually had to show
an id apparently that's restricting
people's right to vote all that's doing
is securing the vote and making it so
that people exactly like you're saying
who actually
play some part in society are actually
voting but apparently that's taking away
people's right to vote no i think that
you're right i think it's too easy to
vote for a lot of people yeah
i think like listen you come like i came
to america i'm like i feel like i owe
america something america doesn't mean
nothing like
america gave me this life so hey i'll
serve the military i owe you i'm in debt
to you america you ain't in debt to me
i'm in debt to you
you you didn't tell me to come here i
chose to come to america 200 other
options and i came to you so i got to
give to you i don't think that messaging
is being given since this one president
that we had that got assassinated years
ago who said don't ask what
your country can do for you instead ask
what you can do for the country when's
the last time we heard that messaging
it's no 5.8 trillion dollar bill let's
let's give more money well why don't we
talk about that and that's perfect with
jfk because jfk was talking a lot about
the federal reserve in his time he did
not like him doing that kind of stuff he
kind of wanted that to be left alone so
biden pitches largest tax hike in
history as part of the 5.8 trillion
dollar budget request he has laid out
the tax hike as part of his 5.8 trillion
budget blueprint for federal spending in
fiscal 2023 which begins in october
under his proposal taxes will rise by
two and a half trillion dollars marking
the largest increase in history and
dollar terms the deficit would be 1.15
trillion dollars the higher taxes would
largely be borne by wall street and the
top silver of u.s households in the form
of steeper corporate rate of modified
wealth tax and a global minimum tax the
taxes outline include a minimum 20 tax
on incomes of u.s households worth a
hundred million dollars or more
the so-called billionaire minimum tax
would raise 361 billion dollars on
revenue over 10 years and apply to the
top
0.01 percent of households or about 20
000 americans the white house said that
roughly half the revenue stem from the
country's 700 billionaires which by the
way mansion comes out the next day and
he shuts the bill down this is a hill
story centrist mansion on tuesday shot
on president's biden plan to raise 360
billion dollars from the imposing a 20
minimum tax on billionaires which is
insane mansion says he doesn't support
the president's plan to tax unrealized
gains on billionaires which would set a
new president nothing new we haven't
heard from mansion you can't tax
something that's not earned earned
income is what we're based on he said
there's other ways to do it everybody
has to pay their fair share mansion
opposition means biden proposal is
likely dead only a day after the white
house unveiled it can you imagine you
write this bill you put all this time
you market it the next dimension says no
there's nothing else you can do about it
that's great well if i'm biden i don't
do anything until i have a conversation
with joe manchin
so
uh how long have i been talking about
joe manchester four years so that's who
i am politically i'm not far left i'm
not sure i should wear a shirt that says
joe team joe mancha
you should you should make sure can we
make that call team joe manchester yeah
actually being serious yeah
um i've been seeing mansion for years
and i'm thinking for years because i
didn't really start really getting into
politics until about 2016. and i'm not a
trump guy i would i'm not a maggot guy
sorry bro i'm sorry but i was a
registered independent and i was like
whatever this guy's doing i'm not i'm
not four
but what what
this guy joe manchin doing something man
he's a democrat in the reddest state in
the country freaking west virginia
and what his
it says here centrist joe manchin
that's what's so amazing about joe
manchin that's what i think is what a
synergist you talk about
we're all americans we might disagree on
a little bit here a little bit here
but like uh what was the whole rodney
can we all just get along
and and it's the fringes that are
causing all these issues in america and
i get it people have core beliefs
but thank god for joe manchin just
basically listen
you know grown-ups are here everyone
just calm down we're not just going to
be set spending like drunk sailors you
know we're going he said he's going to
come out and vote for the the new
supreme court justice uh the black lady
like there's a lot of common sense going
on with joe manchin and and thank god
there's at least a steady hand
in congress that that you know in senate
that we can kind of look towards and say
all right that's
how he kind of you got to conduct
yourself so if i'm biden to bring my
point i i say hey joe this is what i'm
pitching before i spend not smart but
days weeks months haven't put [ __ ]
together is this something you would go
for you know what he should hire his
advisor
joe if you're watching call of duty i'm
open i have to strongly disagree with
you for a second go for it when you're
talking about you know the fringe left
and the fringe right and then you know
kind of of the center which is if it
weren't for these fringe groups and
things would be a lot better but you
know when you look at the republicans
and the democrats in congress i mean
someone like mitch mcconnell is worse
than joe manchin so many of the
republicans are well i agree with you
exactly you know and it's like these are
the people in the middle these are the
people who find common ground all the
time all this kind of stuff but there is
more unity between right-wing populist
and left-wing populists than there is
between me and a rhino republican or is
there really definitely oh yeah because
a rhino republican is fine selling out
our country whereas someone who might be
a left-wing populist doesn't want to
sell our country even if we disagree on
some of these things right and so i
think that a lot of the future of
american politics is actually going to
depend on this left-wing populist
movement because the left historically
has been this anti-big business anti-war
that type of rhetoric right and now you
have people like joe biden bernie
sanders even bernie sanders who is
supposedly one of these guys took one
and a half million dollars from big
pharma for his campaign for his
presidential run right and he talks
badly about big pharma so you have these
people who are all in the middle these
centrist types of people the the rhinos
and the regular democrats who are the
ones that are actually driving
everything up because they work together
and they're basically one of the same so
what i think is that for this 2022
midterm and hopefully for 2024 is that
we get republican candidates who are
actually conservative not like far right
extremist people that's not what i'm
saying but people who actually aren't
just going to be some walk all over me
type of republican actually get
something give an example give names
yeah who who's like all right that's my
guy i like this we're talking about
ideologically then we have tucker
carlson i mean he is the one who is
leading the charge on everything right
now if tucker carlson were to run he'd
be amazing then you have ron desantis
here in florida yes florida
do you actually look at and say that
guy's killing it or lady well i think
marjorie taylor green is one there's
something you that's who you that's the
lady yeah the q and lady dude no not q
another well let's listen there are some
marjorie taylor green
has some very good things when it comes
to actually like think about the january
6 prisoners right there are those people
who are rotting in those dc jails
marjorie taylor green was one of the
only people to stand up and say
something about it you know there's
things that like marjory taylor green
when it came to some of this insider
trading brother
main person that you identify with you
say marjorie taylor we'll see that
should show you how horrible i think the
situation in congress is if that if the
person yeah i will speak to that yeah
exactly that i that i identify the most
with is a marge retailer green
that should show you how screwed up
things are in my opinion i really have
no faith in a lot of the politics that
we have right now i think so much of
this is going to come down to
ideological ideas and that we put too
much credence on as a people in america
on political parties when both the
republicans and the democrats are the
same thing you know if i was a
republican in congress i wouldn't be
signing any of this stuff that other
republicans are signing for and also
none of these people even read the bills
they have some 25 year old guy who
graduated from gw who's in the back room
reading this bill and highlighting it
the night before and then telling the
congressman what it is and they're
hungover doing it probably because
they're on the hill partying and it's
like that's what our political system is
i mean you look at the the spending
bills and what some of that money is
actually going to i mean like stuff
billions of dollars to countries way far
away helping other countries build walls
around their countries to keep them safe
but we can't fund our own border wall
here in america i mean none of this
makes any sense the the politics is just
let me ask you will yeah because you
kind of highlighted something i don't
want to just gloss over it you know we
talk about how on the on the democratic
side of things there's the moderate you
know
democrats and then there's the you know
progressive aoc wing what have you right
and there's that infighting right well
you just highlighted the rhinos right um
you know the classic republican the
reagan republican mcconnells however you
want to classify them and more the maga
wing right where do you think there's a
deeper divide
in the current political
atmosphere is it on the left or is it on
the right it's definitely on the right
yeah there's no doubt about that because
even the moderate
democrats will go along with the sjw
stuff when it comes to the left even if
people are still asking like when it
came to ocasio-cortez's green new deal i
mean that got shot down by everyone in
the senate right like it didn't pass at
all because still even moderate
democrats are asking who's going to pay
for this but when it comes to the the
social justice stuff the the moderate
democrats are still on board with the
left and when you go on twitter like you
go on right wing twitter and you see a
lot of these people who are you know
more of the america first or not like i
personally don't align a lot with the
mega stuff so much now but more of just
a america first agenda i guess you could
say
in a way that you know i'm tired of
spending money in foreign wars and i
want lower taxes and and things to be
able to have a single family income
provide for a family that's kind of
where i'm at but you go on there and you
will see republicans and conservatives
attacking republicans more than they
attack the left a lot of people i think
that the divide between the right right
now is really really stark
did you expect that answer by the way
um yes and no yes and no but it was
interesting you going back and forth
with uh in regards to the uh uh was it
marjorie taylor green
your reaction to it but no i this is why
we have these types of conversations to
see where people stand with different uh
situations all i know is the direction
we're going right now 20 this midterms
that's coming up it's not going to be
pretty for these guys
they have to sit down and re-strategize
what the hell to do numbers came back
with polls for biden 71
is saying biden's america's head in the
wrong direction
uh you know uh uh this is a sunday nbc
news poll this is not a fox poll this is
not a breitbart poll this is not a this
is nbc they're very far right-wing
sunday nbc news poll just 22 say the
country's head in the right direction uh
biden's approval rating is historically
low in fact sunday's poll found biden's
overall job performance
approval rating has declined to 40
percent the lowest of his presidency to
make matters worse seven in 10 americans
expressed no confidence in biden's
ability to deal with the war in ukraine
which is exasperating gas prices and
fuel inflation the average price of gas
has increased by 70 cents since russia
invaded ukraine but gas prices had
already risen by a dollar since biden
assumed office and wage war on americans
and energy independence so look things
are not looking pretty right now with
the handling of businesses
when it comes down to biden the one
that's starting to get very upset i
don't know if you saw what aoc said
about biden like listen we need to kind
of start doing some things because all
the promises he made that we're going to
do this and we're going to do that and
we're going to do this and we're going
to do that
literally nothing he promised is getting
executed yeah because of joe manchin
well and to a certain extent christian
cinema
right so he could have promised that if
joe vince can give a thumbs up about a
thumbs down she'd be the happiest camper
alive i totally get it but the point is
even obama came in and he said
affordable health you know whatever
obamacare that came out what did
obamacare wanted what did obama do with
obamacare they got oh nine executive
decisions like hey here's what we're
doing okay here's what we're doing
democrats are sitting there saying dude
you ain't doing nothing so aoc is saying
we got to be more progressive than we
are today so the left is going after the
left and it's not looking good right and
that the movement of lincoln project is
not as strong today as it was a year and
a half ago if you follow a lincoln
project they don't have the kind of
momentum the height of the trump
presidency that's where they were you
know that's what they were needed so to
speak yeah but that's what gives a [ __ ]
about it yeah today it's not everybody
but if trump runs again they're going to
rear their ugly head again in 2024
they're targeting one guy right now and
one guy only and it's the more and more
they target this guy you have to realize
that's that's who they're fearing who is
that trump you're saying no no no no no
governor governor the state you live in
right now yeah that's who they're
targeting the most which means
in their minds that's their number one
target they think that's going to be a
guy that's going to give them a run for
their money in 2024 if you could i'm
just playing a game throwing it out
there if you could
put someone as the president right now
you know
you have all the votes who would you put
in there right now you don't play this
game though remember we try to play the
there are things about trump that i
liked and trump did get some things done
but trump also cared too much what
people thought about him and so
sacrificed things to not get them done
like well you know we were complaining
about social media censorship for four
years and nothing got done we wanted
more of the wall to get done that didn't
get done desantis has gotten so many
things done as governor it's just been
incredible i mean really a great guy so
i think that desantis knows how to work
these people and he would get things
done like no one else and he gets good
things done i don't disagree with you
pat do you have a do you have an answer
i would go mansion and that i would go
desantis i would yeah i uh
i'd be comfortable with both and maybe
you have margie taylor green as your vp
bro i don't know i'd be comfortable with
both is that who you would put first
desantis right there i think desantis is
uh uh is
uh
on that list what about our local proud
boy who are you voting for
this proud boy thing
you go to one proud boy rally and you
get labeled you're gonna start a bad
rumor you build a thousand bridges you
[ __ ] one goat you know now you're no
longer a bridge builder who's your vote
tyler desantis it's the same okay over
trump for you absolutely a hundred
percent descendants now does that
obviously that can't happen in 2024
there's no way rhonda santa speaks
donald trump in 20 20 20 24 you're
saying there's no way i don't you agree
if trump there's no way trump beats
desantis no no there's no way desantis
beats trump if trump runs in 2024.
that's a real that's really tough to
know it's really tough to know right now
the pulling numbers i mean you look at
the c-pack straw poll and people are
saying trump but again you're also at
cpac and that's kind of that type of
crowd it's not it's not like
50 to 40. it's like 85 percent and the
closest person once trump starts doing
his rallies and rallying the base and
the building
and he finds someone to lock up and lock
her up whoever it is he starts throwing
out hillary yeah exactly that that he's
going to swirl him up yeah
man it's a it's a personality versus
policy policy wise i don't think there's
much difference but desantis is kind of
level-headed yeah and i don't know if
that's enough
to get voted it people like
showmanship is a big deal right and i
don't know if desantis is a showman
there's a thing
trump is losing a lot because of first
of all what he said about the vaccines i
mean talking about that without him
without his vaccines 150 million people
would have died i mean a lot of people
on the right are unvaccinated more than
the left you know myself included
unvaccinated and that makes him lose a
lot of his base and then he's also made
a lot of bad picks for endorsements like
the governor of uh georgia who he
endorsed and uh some of these other
people it's just
i think that he's lost a little bit of
of his edge well the georgia thing was a
debacle behind camp yeah yeah yeah
stacey abrams right
you know the senators are good listen
there's there's points and points and
points you can make about trump versus
desantis let's think about how much of
the debt is due to donald trump because
he expected to be running for another
four years and flip it around and he'd
reverse the things he had done but again
trump started this movement he he
created the rift and exposed the mitt
romney's the george bush's the dick
cheney's i mean he he put these people
under a lamp what all becomes comes
because what are the mcconnells of the
world and the romney's of the world
gonna do
if trump is the nominee are they gonna
try to sink that ship oh yeah definitely
i think well i think that if if trump
wins let's say he wins they're going to
want to get back in his good graces and
say oh we're for you the whole time and
if he loses then they throw him under
the bus but that's not just types of
face games
i feel like and pat this i'll circle
back to you
our country needs to do a better job
of looking up to business people and not
politicians right like the days of jfk
and reagan are so done mm-hmm like
politics is such an ugly game and you
need to be so plain in them you know i
mean you're not getting you grow up
today you don't think a 12 year old boy
grows up today saying one day i want to
be like joe biden
i want to be a senile old man i hope my
daughter grows up but i don't want them
to do that to bite in order i want them
to look at business people that say
i want to build a business i want to
change the world not i want to be a
swampy
congress exactly swamp creature out
there i think that's something that we
need to talk about let me tell you a
story here's a blackrock president says
entitled generation now learning about
shortages okay this is a bloomberg story
rob capito warned that inflation is
having dramatic effects on the economy
with an entire generation now learning
what it means to suffer from shortages
for the first time this generation is
going into a store and not be able to
get what they want and we have a very
entire generation that has never had to
sacrifice the economy is reckoning with
the he bubbled he dubbed scarcity
inflation or to follow from a shortage
of workers agriculture supplies and uh
housing and oil in some regions computer
cofounder new york based blackrock which
is now the world's largest asset manager
with about 10 trillion dollars in client
assets and investments across the global
economy what an interesting thing to say
the entitled generation is about to
learn about shortages well it's like
blackrock are part of the ones who have
screwed people over and so many and they
basically own ten percent of the world's
wealth blackrock it's it's insane how
how deep they go and this is why it's
it's funny when we're talking about the
politics stuff and you know people
arguing about democrat versus republican
and all this is like do you know what's
going on with some of these elites and
the world economic forum people and
these types of people who are in charge
that own so much the the you will owe
nothing and be happy and we're talking
about you know some some things that
just don't really seem to matter it's
like this is what matters it matters
that some
organization like blackrock or vanguard
comes screws you over and then tells you
that it's your fault you know as they're
the ones who are buying up all the
single family homes and turning them
into rental properties so that housing
prices skyrocket and you can't have any
capital yourself
yeah that story from four or five months
ago when you saw that you're sitting
there saying okay remember when tom was
on i don't know if you remember my time
was on and tom's like okay here's what's
going on here's what they're going to do
they're going to increase
you i need to buy now yeah exactly buy
now before these guys pick up a big
market and then you don't have a choice
you don't have another place to go they
can charge you whatever the hell they
want to charge you
but but this inflation thing what he's
explaining the shortages this is not
just that joe biden just came out and
said oh by the way you can expect food
charges shortages because of the
sanctions on russia which to will's
point marjorie taylor greene is one of
the only people to have voted against
sanctions on russia because she saw
these things coming yeah she can see
she can look a few steps ahead and say
oh food shortages are probably more of a
problem to american people than russia
invading ukraine now this is not to
condone the russian of invasion of
ukraine but on the flip side like we're
going to have food shortages on top of
the the supply chain issues we had
during the pandemic the fact that our
transportation secretary blows like
there's a whole mess of things going on
that
maybe we don't need to be putting
sanctions on russia can you share with
us your true feelings tyler next time
don't hold back sometimes i know you'd
like us guys i'll be on the show we do
later tyler pull up this guy rob capito
i just want to highlight this guy
because we've all heard of larry fink
he's the ceo
of blackrock you've heard that name yeah
i've never really heard of um rob capito
so
um
just maybe go to his wikipedia so here's
the hypocrisy that i think is just
laughable with this guy right now
new york city elite went to harvard went
to went to wharton 65 year old male
specializes in more mortgage-backed
securities
okay
so
which tell the history so people know
where this mortgage backs back
securities what is what brought down
that's the big short yeah exactly what
brought down america to its almost knees
in 2008 during the great recession so
like
the millennials are suffering because of
everything that happened in 2008
gen z millennials have been affected by
2008
uh now 2020 everything that happened
with that and here's this
multi-billionaire new york city elite
harvard wharton grad who specializes in
freaking mortgage-backed securities
talking [ __ ] about millennials like
have a little
like like understanding of the world and
and if you want to come to it from a
financial angle hey you need to save
more you need to invest more i get it
but the whole like they've never had to
sacrifice mother effort what have you
ever sacrificed right so like the
hypocrisy is a little annoying to me
that's my opinion
but other than that he's an awesome guy
exactly i love him yeah we go out for
drinks he's a fantastic guy yeah no the
whole thing with blackrock and those
types of investment firms is really
terrible the people have no idea what's
actually going on but that goes to show
you what he said i think he knows
exactly what he's saying and i think it
goes to show the level of arrogance that
these people have that they know that
they can just get away with whatever
they want like think about on twitter
right now where just like what was it a
year ago with the whole hunter bite and
laptop thing and all that you couldn't
say it new york post got banned and now
new york times and twitter all these
people are saying oh it actually was
true and it's totally fine 500 days
later yeah 500 days later so it's like
oh so you can say all these things or
and and say whatever you want to people
and just have this level of arrogance
and they always just get away with it
they know they're going to get away with
it i know they can get away with saying
this and
and doing whatever they want basically
by the way i got to give shout out to
adam adam you've been getting a lot of
love today super chat raul adam is so
underrated he is a man's man and my
favorite jewish person oh wow
rahul you just made adam's day favorite
by the way this clip needs to be cut and
shown to your mom
mom you knew he was going to be a rabbi
he's on his nobody thinks i'm going to
be a rabbi i don't know just wait till i
show you some of the ones that haven't
been
not enough can i read you one close on
the podcast
of course
here's one comment a guy i got to give
this guy a shout out
um
he said this
this is from uh tyler durden tyler
durden that's from fight club all right
so it's a three sentence thing he goes
adam i owe and i owe you an internet
troll apology i didn't like you for the
longest time after watching a few of
these and listening to you and your
guests on your show sauce cast in a
non-political light you're not a bad
dude at all turns out i'm just a
judgmental prick
good luck to you and keep up the good
work thanks tyler there you go buddy is
it your name tyler there you go is that
you you pizza by the way i put out that
story from uh uh from babylon b uh i
don't know if you guys saw this or not
it's very important for us to share this
so did you see this but put this up so
people can see it adam look at this the
only florida compliant pain relieving
cream
under florida law being gay forced to
rebrand that shout out to seth dylan
he doesn't hold back you know this guy
that dylan yeah yeah he's met him a
couple times he's great
you work so bad they're not slowing down
they're not slowing down so a complete
different topic here a completely
different topic here
corrupting popular mascot disney mascot
roaming park without any pants
whoever's coming up with these ideas man
you gotta give him credit is that that
donald duck is that i have no idea who
it is but by the way just a different
question different question completely
different topic i've been wanting to
talk about this kirsten know what you
guys think have you seen a new batman
have you seen it have you seen a new
batman no you gotta be kidding me i'm
really watching you i don't watch movies
have you seen a new batman or no
unfortunately i've heard it's phenomenal
you
did you watch the joker yeah it was a
joker you watch a joke what'd you think
about the joker i thought joker was well
made you thought it was well moving you
liked the story line yeah what the story
was
yeah it was gritty i'm a big joaquin
phoenix guy and i think he crushed it
but the store so i watched batman uh
whatever the last batman is with uh
vampire which by the way penguin crushed
it penguin was uh uh colin farrell i
couldn't believe that that was colin
farrell until i i am debated and i'm
like you got to be kidding me colin
farrell
penguin can you pull up the picture
colin farrell penguin in the recent
background you have to watch it just
because of colin it'll never be danny
devito bro look at this look at this so
he plays
that's not even a good picture there's a
put the other one with colin farrell and
wright he plays the penguin colin phil
and absolutely can i see what color
looks like in real life these days by
the way are we talking about the same
column same column feral guy that uh
that guy yes he played so anyway so
here's the part with the story i'm
curious
were you a kid that grew up reading the
comic books were you did you read
batman's stories i didn't read comic
books i mostly write animal books tyler
did you or no no i can't read you it's
okay so did you did you always can't
read it you guys did i was i'd like
archie and uh betty and uh
this entire thing i did like a little
bit so let me tell you what bothers me
with the story do you know what they
painted thomas wayne to be in the movie
like probably i can only imagine that a
horrible white rich billionaire yeah so
so what they added to it is they added
in the story that thomas wayne
paid off carmine a mobster to eliminate
and silence a journalist who ends up
killing the journalists so here the
original crime uh yeah is this an mbs no
no no no no but hear me out hear me out
what happens here with the story so i
watch batman i'm sitting there thinking
i didn't take my kids i watch it before
i decide to take my kids and my kids i'm
not going to watch it with them right
now
for a minute we watch movies like this
they like batman we're not watching it
so here's here's the biggest thing that
concerned me with it number one i mean
the whole thing is about
rich people privileges all this other
stuff which by the way obviously some of
that exists but think about who should
be the only person to change the history
of thomas wayne's character the only
person i believe should have the right
to change thomas wayne's character
history of his characters the guy who
created the character thomas wayne i
don't think you can go back i think you
can go forward and change ways here's
every time you look at batman what'd you
think about his father you thought he
was a what good guy you thought he was a
guy that was successful guy
you know did good he was wayne
enterprise yeah win enterprises he was
like a guy you looked at almost like
iron man when you think about
you know robert downey jr playing it i
watched batman and i got off i'm like is
the average person watching this how are
you going to admire thomas wayne you're
not and you see batman being conflicted
with his father and having hate for his
fight
very very interesting what they're doing
with some of these movies where it's all
about division everything's about
division everything's about how much
hate and anger you can have for somebody
that succeeded and look what they had to
do something to get to the top
i got into a debate with this one guy on
twitter
who said uh uh he said he had like a
couple hundred thousand followers and
verified guy and he says you know uh
i bet anybody that became rich got to
the top hurting somebody like think
about if that is something that people
say over and over and over again and
people start believing it what do you
start thinking about the only way i'm
ever going to be rich is what i got to
hurt others to get to the top if that
becomes a consensus and you're talking
about we need to make business people as
heroes people who are independent you
know going out there winning for
themselves why would you how could you
look up to somebody like that the the
media the tv the shows the movies
everything is demonizing those guys
where those guys cannot be heroes can i
can i
um
give you a compliment
it's just like a payback after the one i
gave you yeah raul gave it to you that's
not it thank you but i'm gonna give you
something okay let's let's hear you out
uh i i i know why you're such a big
advocate for america um that's obvious
you could yeah any any any
uh immigrant who comes here and flees
iran or flees venezuela or flees
freaking north korea uh naomi park
understandable
anyone can digest that in a second
the capitalism component and your love
for capitalism it takes
it takes a deeper understanding
for the economic systems to understand
why you love capitalism so much let me
go deeper
um
i've seen firsthand how you run your
business
you know when i met you it was 2010
you were just starting out you were just
you were dude you had i think tom or
more with you
um you were you were
prior to you starting php you were kind
of like me
you were you know a guy doing his thing
making money
but you didn't have a whole team team
team behind you
you know you said something to me one
time you go how many what's the most
amount of people you've ever let i'm
like i don't know maybe like you know a
dozen or so you're like yeah i've got 20
000 insurance agents
that work for my company
okay
and
i've seen not only like the wealth that
you've been able to create but it's what
you've been able to create for other
people and i've seen the workers who are
crushing it the ricky and erica's the
guy tons the johnny masons the
sao paulo
matt sheena and i've seen where they
were and what they were doing and what
you where they're at now chris hart you
mentioned all these guys elvis i mean i
can go down the list of what they would
be doing
if they hadn't met you
six figures would have been a dream and
now seven figures is a reality but they
need the capitalist with the idea to say
follow my lead mother suckers i got you
if you work hard and you buy into the
system and you follow what i'm basically
saying and
you're free to run your business you can
you can make your dreams a rally and
i've seen it time and time and time
again and that was so so amazing
part of the reason i kind of wanted to
tell you about the erica thing erica
aguilera shout out to ricky and erica
she said that before she met you she was
like working at a she was picking eggs
and strawberries
like in california in bakersfield she
comes you she says let me use my skill
set i'm a networker and now they're
making seven figures it's insane yeah
but unless there's a capitalist who says
follow my lead but like there's so many
people that probably want to vilify you
look at pat he's rich his kids are you
know get to go to private school it's
like you have no clue where this guy
came from from iran
it's going to the army to build a
business with six people that you almost
went out of business and now look at you
now but like nobody wants to hear that
story they just want to say ah the
freaking rich guy but you know who i
relate to here's who i relate to shout
out to the people on php thank you for
that you know who i relate to you know
i'm having this comment here that hey
you do
do you think i asked john remember you
were in the room we were talking to john
and i said john you think i relate more
to billionaires you think i relate more
to the guy making 20 bucks an hour and
he says oh you relate more to
billionaires i said nope i relate to the
other guy why is that
it's just a regular outcome there's
nothing special about me there's
thousands of people that have done also
what i've done tens of thousands of
people that i've done there's nothing
special about
one guy doing this the idea is this
system
i trust this concept of a system that
gives an average guy to go out there and
change their lives that's the biggest
thing so if we don't like it growing up
as a kid whoever your dad viewed as a
hero you pretty much also viewed as a
hero
some kids are like oh who you be michael
jordan's the best michael jordan's the
best yeah you know what the michael
johnson how magic johnson's the best
greatest president of all time is jfk
the greatest person of all time is jfk
like i sat down with general mcchrystal
and i'm like why do you believe in the
policies that you do you're a four-star
your dad was a two-star because i grew
up in a liberal family jfk this is that
okay now i get it you know you'll so but
if we don't paint the picture of the
right hero america has a hero making
machine problem i'm telling you right
now america and the media has a hero
making machine problem they're making
the wrong people into heroes and kids
growing up are confused we need to go
back to
turning the right people into heroes and
at the same time the people that were
building up into heroes we can't say
they're
perfect everybody's got flaws
everybody's got issues everybody's got
challenges but hey if you give your best
one day you can also make an impact in
the world i think that's the message and
you go deeper on who we're making heroes
and who do you think should be well let
me ask you this does hillary clinton
qualify to be an international women's
day hero for forbes a business magazine
100 absolutely i mean i know you believe
that tyler but the question becomes does
she qualify for that tell me tell me a
hundred people
women specifically let's let's let's
take 10 of them right now give me 10
women
that would make for a better
international woman's day
hero than a hillary clinton
or oprah 100 whoever obama
uh entrepreneur business not michelle
obama okay this is business oprah for
sure sheryl sandberg yes
i think absolutely sheryl sandberg the
girl that did the spanx what's what's
her name the spanx uh you know when she
started that company right i like lori
grenier from um uh shark tank barbara
corcoran chris barbara quarterback in
the 2016 primary from ibm uh the ceo of
ibm who she ran in 2016. i can't
remember her name oh the blonde lady by
the way she's awesome even meg whitman
you can i got i got a thousand names of
women i can put ahead of hillary you're
confusing the kid who's reading forbes
saying i gotta grow up to be like her
that's not a hero you got better people
to put as heroes than that this is what
i was saying is that we need to build up
the business people and the
entrepreneurs and stop
idolizing these politicians left or
right yeah right okay what have they
ever done what have they ever built oh
carly florian yeah fiorina
she's actually at one point she was
pretty good but the trump went after her
pretty
yeah uh
trump called her ugly and horse face to
her face
to her face i can't believe something's
like i think i would say he called chris
he goes ted cruz your wife is ugly as
[ __ ] do i have your vote yes sir
what
okay but to your point they made they
made hillary clinton international woman
of the year and all she's done is ruin
several women's lives right and get
convicted rapists or
potential convicted rapist off the hook
and she's not provided any value for
anybody but you know what that that that
that that hurts
the girl who was 12 years old with a
dream of running a successful business
that hurts her
she paid the price we need to turn her
into a hero right it's hard running a
business it's hard running a business
and have a marriage that works and have
kids and it's
listen it's already so hard to be a
working mom
than to be a working mom and running a
business and you're the face and you
have kids i'm sorry i i'm a father who
runs a business and i do a lot of
different things and i'm you know the
companies that i run
but to do that and nurse and raise kids
and do en and and that's a hero so like
you have such a great opportunity to
turn some of these folks into heroes we
miss the mark it's like amy connie
barrett she's got six kids seven kids
remember her senate hearing and they
said what notes do you have and she
pulled up a blank sheet of paper and
knew everything by heart i mean she's an
exceptionally brilliant woman and what
do they do they demonize her it's the
handmaid's tale all over it but by the
way but but this is not about democrats
and republicans because oprah winfrey is
a democrat but oprah winfrey went from
the story of her being raped as a girl
to
actress per what was the movie purple i
think
to then you coming and winning building
a show you become like the ultimate
podcaster in the world for two decades
three decades whatever the timeline is
and the next thing you know you're a
billionaire you have your own media
company yeah now by the way there's a
lot of people that can't stand here i
salute a person that went from there
let's get another 10 more oprah winfreys
in the world right let's inspire 50 more
oprah winfrey so i think it's a hero
making machine that's broken what do you
think yeah it depends on if oprah
winfrey is going to come out and tell
people to do what she did or if she's
now because she's had some interviews
where she's focused on some of the race
stuff and some of the social justice
stuff so if she's inspiring young women
or men even to to pursue that same path
and make something of themselves and go
against the grain and be that type of
strong person then that's great but you
have to understand these these types of
people who are heroes now you know
they're they're the people who society
wants to be the heroes like think about
the black community and some of the
heroes that they have you know some of
these rappers and people who are in many
of their songs are preaching horrible
values you know things that are
absolutely terrible for a lot of
african-american communities when it
comes to the drug use when it comes to
the the way that they spend their money
not saving money and spending on jewelry
and things and the way you treat women
all of those kind of things though but
those are someone's hero right so one of
those rappers is some of these people
here and for white people too and those
are the people the society wants to be
the heroes because they know that you
can be controlled if you don't have any
good role models but this is again why
somewhere like black lives matter says
we want to disband the western nuclear
family which was on their website
because your dad should be your hero
your mom should be your hero your family
those people your heroes are someone you
look up to to get good values from but
if you don't have that then you get
values from these types of people you
get heroic qualities from these types of
people that society puts in place to be
that role model for you they want these
bad people to be people's heroes i i
don't disagree but so somebody right now
said you know oprah push for obama no
good
i don't care
i don't care hear me out
i will take
a hundred thousand
democrats who can't stand trump and
republicans
to choose to go and bust their ass like
oprah did and become successful i'll
take that any day of the week and if she
wants to get oprah to uh the next obama
to become a president go you earned the
right to bust your ass for 30 years i
don't have to agree with obama's policy
i respect the diligence it takes for 30
years for you to become as relevant as
you are that is a hero it's not about
policies that's a hero we can have a
debate oprah nine sit down and say
listen man we disagree in the following
areas let me tell you what i do agree i
guarantee your discipline shows imagine
how many for 30 years you're doing the
show you you getting flus cold your
voice someone died crisis negative
ratings dropped for like a year then you
know you got this other guy that came
and took over there's robert downey not
robert downey something morton downey jr
owns the show for two years and montel
comes and this guy comes and that guy
comes and you still stay relevant for 30
years there's a lot everybody can learn
from this
all i'm saying is sometimes we got to
set aside politics and we got to
recognize effort diligence to get to the
top then we can have a political
conversation as well so i like values
are more important than politics it it
there is no way you can by the way you
know one time when oprah winfrey's like
dude we're paying way too much taxes i
don't know if you guys remember when
this wasn't a story it's a little too
much taxes guess what typically happens
to somebody that makes it to the top by
working their asses off there's a little
bit of them sitting back and realizing
i can't say that you worked as hard as i
did there's no way in the world i should
be paying taxes take care of you that
naturally the conservative beliefs
naturally also happens to someone like
that so anyways all i'm saying is i
don't think we have the right heroes
uh that we're building up okay
prenuptial agreements you're about to
get married right you just proposed to
your girl okay and
answer them
that's fantastic out of all the places
in the world right as that's you say
muzzle tough yeah thank you cnn has some
advice for you okay cnn a lot of
credibility
prenuptial agreements aren't just for
the rich here's what you should know few
people get married thinking they're
going to get divorced or about divvying
up money or assets after marriage ends
but more brides and grooms to be are
considering that scenario especially
when it comes down to prenuptial
agreements
these agreements are not just for the
wealthy and powerful 62 percent of
divorce attorneys said they saw an
increase in clients requesting a prenup
with a significant uptick in millennials
signing them in general prenups can be
helpful for couples in which there's an
existing
existing wealth imbalance or there might
be one later on even if people aren't
wealthy now some clients have reasons to
believe they will be for example if
they're in a medical school or except
expect an inheritance or other reasons
what are your thoughts on what cnn
is saying which by the way i'm surprised
cnn wrote this article what are your
thoughts on cnn saying prenuptial
agreements are good i think this is what
happens when you take god out of
marriage i think this is what you have
when you have a secular society that
that doesn't value marriage as an
institution between a man a woman of god
or
people who are creating god's image it's
when you have a society that is built
totally just on again the politics and
these types of worldly possessions and
things it tells you that oh hey you know
you there's a pretty good chance that
you're not going to stay together this
this agreement that you're making with
your significant other isn't sacred it's
nothing that's really that important you
can end it at any time and it's not a
big deal and you know you should sign
and make sure that you get your money so
i think that
it's telling people that you don't need
to stay together you don't need to work
out your problems you don't need to to
toughen up and get through it just end
it you know who cares just end it screw
your kids and and and the the covenant
you made with god all this just screw it
and
move on move on i think that's i think
it's bad would would you get a prenup
before you get married no you would not
i don't think so no all right you don't
think so so he's considering to think so
it's like maybe a little bit there's
like a percentage 10 percent changes
oh man look at that look honestly
she's gonna watch this you know well
yeah yeah
you're gonna have to have this tough
talking anyway we gotta cut the spark
title we gotta cut the spotlight
can you see the sweat going down my face
yeah no i i think it's you know probably
like a 90 10 yeah you would not that i
wouldn't what happens if she goes i'd
like to get a burrito
i don't think that's going to happen if
she does we can have that discussion but
you know again in our point of view with
how we are as a couple it's like the man
okay would lead on these guys you're
going to discuss this though with her
right yeah i'm sure we'll discuss it and
everything but as well home record it
hasn't even started yet i know
you think this is a comfortable
conversation you have it with your wife
it's going to get worse so how about you
if you get one i did have a prenup and i
my marriage didn't work and thank god i
had the prenup because i had all the
money right so and i told her i'm not
marrying you unless i get the printer
she goes yeah that's fine yeah and you
guys do you think that having that that
prenup makes it not just with you but in
general makes it so that people feel
more
safe getting divorces
i think that's an interesting
perspective i think you know everyone
needs an exit strategy right so it's an
exit strategy yeah i think
because i think people get divorced too
easily well maybe you're right yeah
no i got it very easily don't worry
about that yeah
i was in a
i was you know i probably shouldn't have
gotten married at the time but yeah now
i had a will smith thing going on um
but
i will say look numbers don't lie 50 of
marriages end in divorce
99
of relationships don't work out right
meaning like how many relationships do
you have before you end up getting
married and then the marriage doesn't
work
so
i look
if you have
money you know you want to throw god in
the equation and the holy trinity sister
whatever a rabbi like
there's a chance something's going to go
wrong right and
if you're worth a couple million bucks
and your wife ain't worth nothing and 10
years later
she's worth a couple million bucks and
you're worth nothing that doesn't sit
well with you bro right okay well that's
definitely true but again it goes back
to you know if you are it's about people
being more dedicated to marriage you
have to instill better values than
people which is very difficult to do of
course i love you know i'm giving best
case scenarios on what i if you're 25
women i'll talk about i feel like
like i respect him like as a man but i
also think like like he's like a little
brother like right you're 25 like i get
it you know what i'm saying like right
so of course
and all these types i do have any advice
as like i think i look at pat as like a
a mentor big brother friend yeah you
know so do you have advice for the kids
out there with friends i
i fully believe in prenups because
uh
you have to you you can
you can be held responsible for you
changing which you will but you have to
protect yourself against somebody else
who chooses to change because you're not
god so for me prenup is about you not
acting like your god that's actually
more
of a
i'm not god to say well
this is 100 gonna work then you're
saying you're god because you control
the other person i'm not god i don't
control my wife my wife gets to do
whatever she wants to do but a prenup to
me was protecting her she knew what was
going to be taking care of the kids
where she didn't have to worry about
anything
and we put it together and she's happy
we're happy and it's good to go i think
prenups
actually eliminate arguments because
sometimes people have thoughts about
what the other person's motive is if you
have a prenup in place it's eliminated
because that motive is on the paper what
can you do like a trust a living trust
and estate planning all these things
that you got to do every business deal
i've done with a handshake dude i love
you man it's awesome we all like those
right home
two years later that guy's no longer
working and you're carrying the weight
for the company and the guys goes to
costa rica for nine months and i have to
carry it away for the office i'm like
[ __ ] i never put that in the contract so
i have to do my part and i gotta pay
this guy and i got
man i wish i had that in the business
agreement i didn't do it so so you know
and relationships friendships marriages
people change i believe people change
and the biggest insurance policy of you
not being god and knowing that if people
change your protective she's protected
as a prenup but to each his own that's
on you when you do that anyways i think
he's got some callers
that uh do we have any callers or no
yeah we got a few callers
by the way you got 10 minutes max
so when we get the callers in they got
20 seconds to ask the question we'll get
right into it so john if you got a
caller let's go through it you got only
10 minutes john
all right we have a lose
do you ever lose
hi lose
guys my question was um concerning
when we were talking about talking about
sex education in school
i'm 47 i went to school in dade county
and
what we learned was health education
which basically was
you just learning about biology learning
our reproductive system being puberty
that was it didn't get into sexual
orientation
so but my question that i had even
concerning that was
how can you
as a mom raising boys and you guys are
men
what what was your advice on helping
them becoming better men
i think that's a good question i will
tell you one of the best books i ever
read was by james dobson raising up boys
if you got boys you got to read the book
raising up boys
that book talks about how old's your son
by the way
just out of curiosity
your sons how old are they
they are nine and eight okay so they
haven't yet gone through the phase of
the uncomfortable you walking in on them
and they want to be in the room by
themselves and you're wondering if
they're going through the depression
they're not they just figured out their
favorite toy in the world that they not
know how to use
where's the where's the father in the
situation where's the man
the father is is
in their lives and we are together okay
that's good that's the biggest thing we
differ sometimes on certain things and i
of course he tells me okay that's that's
a situation that you need to stay out of
yeah i can't say anything and i go to
him like well yeah they come to me what
do i say yeah it's by the way it's a
great concern this is where the man
needs to step up if i may we were
educated in the same system by the way
lucy i went to miami-dade county public
schools shout out 305. but if my mom
tried to have a conversation with me
about masturbating when i was 12 years
old i would die yeah okay this is where
the dad what's happening is that what
movie
it's what movie is that when she walks
in no no not american pie it's uh it's
transformers transformers
stop that's not comfortable you don't
say that stop it get out and even same
happy times if you're playing with
little something i don't know what you
said she played by the way she crushed
it in that movie by the way even it
might be uncomfortable with the dad but
i think
if you're raising boys
an uncle
like a family figure father figure you
know male
person that you can trust can have those
kind of conversations nothing is more
awkward than having sex talks with your
mom here's my biggest here's my biggest
advice to you is that so many parents
want to be helicopter parents they want
to watch over everything their kids are
doing make sure they're safe
little boys and young men are not going
to be safe you need to let your kids
make mistakes especially young men
because early mistakes that young men
make learning that failure is okay and
how to rebuild after failure prepares
them for life if you don't fail as a
young man you aren't doing it right and
if you're a parent who doesn't let your
kid fail and doesn't actually give them
consequences for when they fail they're
going to be weak men so train them to
fail train them to to learn the hard way
and they're gonna they're gonna great
point by will you can take that to the
bank you lose hope
okay
who else we got john here we go and just
real quick on that man be a good role
model like we talked about that with
fresh and fit like i have a daughter and
i want to be a good role model to my
daughters yeah she marries somebody like
me and i set the right example i love
even with fathers man be a good role
model
i love that all right we have lisa
lisa how are you
dvd
how you doing lisa how awesome i'm doing
well thank you
very cool so what's on your mind lisa
um i just had a you know i i was
listening to the podcast and i've heard
a couple of uh comments on how the
i guess where you are they're they're
considering doing gender studies in
schools yeah
how do you feel about that
well i'm a little confused i you know
wasn't really um sure that teachers were
equipped with this type of knowledge to
start teaching
the children
on this stages of their life i know that
they're very impressionable at this age
and i know that there's quite a bit
going on
mentally physically hormones um and
things going you know amongst children
and so um
what do you think we should do about it
what do you think we should do about it
um you know for gender studies i mean
don't get me wrong i'm certainly one of
those people who believe that people
should be who they are
um and if they're ex you know
exuberating feelings towards that
you know um
how much is it because they're
impressionable
is it because their friends are
um and how much is it because they are
truly having those feelings
we agree do you have any thoughts on
that do you remember that old nor
macdonald bit you might have seen
anywhere he got heckled where he said he
was talking about the real heroes and
that teachers were not the real heroes
and if you wanted to be a second grade
teacher all you need is a third grade
education
and it's like i think there's a lot that
actually there's some truth to that that
these teachers are not equipped to teach
a lot of this stuff i mean i don't think
they know i mean i know people when i
was going through college who became
teachers they're drinking their way
through college they get seized in a lot
of their classes past with a teaching
degree and now they're going and
teaching kids about sexual education and
all this stuff it is very strange i
think that again like always come back
to this but parents need to have a
greater role in this type of stuff as
well the parent can teach this stuff to
the children you can make it not awkward
there are resources about learning how
to do it the right way but parents just
at the end of the day if you take
anything from this from me at all today
just parents need to have a bigger role
in their kids lives and a lot of this
stuff swages itself away i agree lisa
thank you for calling and have a great
day lisa
so so john let's see it's either john is
only picking women or we only have women
as well hey i'm excited to see if we get
a third usually happens when i'm
launching
usually just women calling in the cops
john let's go one more johnny last one
here last one here buddy
all right we got a member from the lgbtq
here we go okay let's go
john is that you or is that somebody
else
is is john the one that wants to ask the
question or did we lose somebody john no
i think it's i think it's rude
i'm sorry any do you have another one
john or are you good
we're good okay sounds good well that
would have been exciting if we had
something yeah i had one question where
are they the l the g the b the t the k i
wanted to know what the i or the a is so
i can read part of what they said and
absolutely dude oh we got him okay oh
cool
we got three minutes
i think it's rudy hello
yes is this uh what's your name
my name is apple texas and i'm part of
the lgbtq community okay
and i do not i disagree with all of that
okay tell us why the children
at that age that they use it for their
mind
they're not going through emotions
because they're growing up and that's
what causes people to commit suicide
because those threats are going to cover
your mind regardless
they will go into it they have to have
questions when they're older they'll go
to their parents or somebody
other than
so let me let me because the audio's a
little choppy i want to make sure the
audience hears it so you're part of the
lgbtq community and you think teaching
that too early is dangerous
oh yes very very very that's too young
well then rudy
at what age did you know you're part of
the lgbtq community
um growing up i just felt different but
as i got older and i realized what was
going on with my body then i realized it
was a choice that i made
do you remember how old you were how old
were you when you made that choice
how old were you when you made that
choice
i fixed it okay got it and 10th grade 10
that that's the age 10th grade
got it and that's because i mean that's
what your body starts to you know
experience things you have questions you
look it up or you read about it you
figure it out but if you do that to a
child when they're growing up they're
already going through so much emotions
most people in the community of lgbtq
have problems in their own family and
adding that extra pressure at that young
age is very dangerous rudy how old are
you right now if you don't mind me
asking
sir how old are you right now if you
don't mind me asking
why not i'm four years old i grew up in
the uh early 90s
got it you're 40 years back when it was
just like we treated the
sir you're a man who's gay
yes i'm a gay man i don't believe in
another step that is just that's how you
feel so i know we're running out of time
but what does the lgbt community get
wrong in your opinion
in my opinion i think that they have
bastardized
what people that are part of that
community what we did back in the day
was our gay rights which is to be
treated the same equal we didn't want to
be married we wanted to be on our own
things
because when that's the way we were
separated
i think they have picketed it and they
have
just
made it very nasty with this whole
sexual
you know
in the window they're doing this after
you know the gay pride they have just
made it bastardize it it's sickening
well rudy first of all a different
perspective thank you for coming on and
sharing that with us we appreciate you
have a wonderful day thanks for
listening
you said you are a democrat no god no oh
you're you're you're you're a gay
republican
let's go
but actually i became a republican actor
uh hillary i needed to vote for him
got it yes very interesting very
interesting perspective i'd love to
learn more about your story and i hope
parents fight that bill i mean they
don't fight they'll keep the way it is
not mess with the kids
leave the babies alone i'm agreeing well
thank you have a wonderful day rudy
appreciate you thank you god bless you
god bless you bye bye bye bye
uh pretty interesting we should start
the calls a little bit earlier next time
we'll go 20 minutes next on top a few
more callers will final thoughts here
i'm going to leave it up to you by the
way folks we're going to put the link
let's put the link below to the book
how to win friends and uh influence
enemies as well as the link to find them
on twitter we put the handle everywhere
uh how are you feeling about the future
of america are you optimistic um i'm
gonna quote dennis prager here he was my
boss so i kind of i'm legally obliged
he's a good guy we like him he is he is
but you know he talks about being an
optimist or a pessimist and for me i'm
either an optimist or a pessimist
because an optimist thinks things are
going to be good so why would i fight a
pessimist thinks things are going to
suck so why would i fight so all i
really care about for anyone is that
they fight because there are a lot of
fights to be had whether that's at your
school board whether that's in politics
whether that's at your church whether
that's in values of even within your own
family or maybe it's things that within
yourself you know you want to change or
do with your business whatever it is
there are fights to be had and so don't
think of it in terms of optimists or
pessimists just think of it in terms
that you are going to fight anyway
because you know what the truth is and
you know what's morally right gotta love
it and i love yeah go ahead i was gonna
say uh if you like the conversation with
will today we're doing another show in
an hour from now 12 o'clock on facebook
on vt
we're going to talk dating lifestyle
money and we're going to hear more
of a relaxed will you know let your hair
down a little bit you get the best hair
in the conservative game so that's what
they said we're going to have some
ladies on the show we're gonna have some
dialogue so tune in one hour from now
on valuetainment money tomorrow debate
of the century debate of the century
tomorrow sync
from young turks
we'll see you guys there take care
everybody bye bye bye bye
you